[Music]
one of the occupational hazards of doing
a show like this is that my friends my
family people who come up to me at the
grocery store and at IKEA and pretty
much everyone that I encounter on a
day-to-day basis wants to talk politics
with me fortunately I love talking about
politics and talking to people about
politics so I'm usually happy to engage
with people even when I'm picking out an
ice cream or testing out the cubic couch
which is surprisingly comfortable and
easy to put together one of the things
I've noticed lately about our political
climate is that people are having a
harder time tuning out of politics even
briefly to talk about other things this
is somewhat antidotal in my case
particularly but I bet that it's
happening to you in your life too
suddenly it seems like every
conversation is political every
discussion somehow gets back to Trump
and yes your aunt knows exactly how to
solve America's health care crisis even
though she can't figure out how to sink
or iPad on face value none of this is a
problem I love the people who were
largely a political are now becoming
more politically engaged people are not
only talking about politics but in many
cases reevaluating what their beliefs
are because of the upside-down world
that we live in right now while
everything may seem crazy I really do
believe this time that we're in right
now is a rare special moment when so
many people are all doing the same
introspection about their beliefs all at
the same time whether this will lead to
more or less freedom - more or less
tolerance or more or less peace all
remains to be seen
but without question we're in some
pretty fertile ground for change right
now and by change I mean real societal
change not just hope and change one
problem I do see attached to all of this
opportunity for change and re-evaluation
is that people are becoming consumed by
politics in a way which doesn't strike
me as particularly healthy for humans
mental state or for societies at large
it's one of the reasons I'm a small
government guy I want a government small
enough that we don't have to talk about
it that much because it doesn't even
have the power to do too much good or
too much bad there's melting trade-off
there small government can only do so
much the rest is up to the people so if
you want government
do everything you really can't complain
when it does all sorts of things that
you don't like
well actually of course you can complain
about it at least until that big
government comes and takes away your
right to do just that so my message to
you this week is let's keep talking
about all of these issues let's keep
staying engaged and trying to change
things for the better but at the same
time let's not let it consume us to the
point where it changes who we are social
media can be an awful catalyst to the
endless focus on politics which is why
I've been trying to take the weekends
off and focus on the world that exists
in front of my face instead of one that
exists in 140 characters when you are
online though try to find some nuance
between trump derangement syndrome and
nazi frog obsession most people are good
and want pretty much the same things
that you do so let's keep growing that
new center and as long as you're here
right now we're once again partnering up
with learn Liberty this week and we've
got author and director of the
philosophy politics and economics
department at Duke University dr. Mike
Munger we're going to talk politics
philosophy economics and much more watch
and learn
unless it's the weekend
[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
the fine folks over at learn Liberty
today and joining me is an economist and
author and a professor of political
science at Duke University dr. Mike
Munger
welcome to the Reuben report it's great
to be here that introduction just makes
it sound like I'm confused and that's
probably right I thought it made you
sound very professional well I have
several disciplines that I try to
contribute in yeah well we're going to
talk about those several disciplines but
first let's just talk about political
science because I was a political
science major explains a lot I good or
bad good all good oh well good okay I
like to think that I'm one of the few
people that's using political a
political science degree actually to
talk about politics and political
philosophy so my first question to you
would be do you think that political
science right now is sort of needed more
than ever just to understand the basic
philosophies behind so much of the
craziness that we see in public
discourse these days well for two
reasons one political science studies
engineering but it studies the
engineering of rules and we tend to have
this idea that what we need is better
people we're probably not going to get
better people but we may need is better
rules the question is how to try to do
that the other thing political science
does is look at some of the ethical
questions that have plagued given beings
for the last 3,000 years so I see
political science as being a kind of
ideal liberal arts degree that combines
an analysis and ethics but so of course
I think and I would I'm a political
science professor that we need more
political science but I really do worry
that people just think we can ignore the
Constitution of the living Constitution
we'll change it to interpret it the way
that we want it we don't understand
enough about rules to be able just to
change it willy-nilly and have it turn
out well so I like what you said there
about that we can't change people that
much a lot of people seem to think that
that's what politics should be right we
should actually change the way your
opinions are about very personally held
things through public college shoes the
new Messiah
everybody Morocco Obama was going to be
the new Messiah he got a Nobel Peace
Prize
have we been in office for seven months
yeah so the this emphasis on this next
person is going to be the one and you
see it worldwide but it's a little
surprising to see the u.s. succumb to it
also
yeah so as a you do consider yourself a
libertarian right you ran into labor
talk we're going to get to that and I am
I am certainly a libertarian and in the
sense that I am NOT a Republican okay
and I want to unpack the differences
between that and then talk about sort of
the ever-changing label thing which is
sort of becoming meaning at the moment
so with all the political philosophies
out there do you sense that some of the
freedom stuff is taking root right now
because I it's think to me things are
going crazy right now but I sense that
liberty reason getting back to some of
the Constitution stuff I do sense people
talking about a little bit more now than
perhaps two years ago well right I had a
bunch of colleagues who after Trump was
elected up colleagues at Duke yeah so
political science professors and other
people on the Left who would come into
my office and sheepishly say you know
you were right all this stuff about we
need to worry about the constitutional
powers of the president when george w
bush was president they were worried
mm-hmm with brock obama they said I
don't mind so much as long as my guy is
in charge that's the point
a guy won't always be in charge so what
you might want best is a dictator that
you can pick right that's not how it
works where i means that we have to have
rules and it's very frustrating the
Constitution builds in conflict and
Barack Obama in many ways was a terrible
president in trying to negotiate things
with the Congress he would prefer to go
make speeches yeah he liked that Messiah
thing so I do think that a lot of people
on the Left are much more worried now
about sort of traditional constitutional
protections of freedom of speech and
about the separation of powers so the
number of them have actually said you
know those federalist papers that really
interesting aren't they yes welcome back
yeah
so when george w bush was signing
executive actions i assume you were
basically against them when when barack
obama was signing like so you were
basically against them i zoom when
you're not thrilled
right now with the amount that that
Trump is done but that's really
interesting to me that your colleagues
on the Left are suddenly gone oh now I
get it you know we have people on the
left now fighting for states rights
because they don't want the Fed coming
in and closing sanctuary cities which i
think is what a phenomenal but I can't
help but gleefully remind them you know
you told me that was code for racism but
now you're for states rights because
you're worried about medical marijuana
you're worried about same-sex marriage
states rights it's true was misused by
advocates of segregation that's
absolutely right Hitler was a vegetarian
it doesn't mean that all vegetarians are
not Caesar doesn't mean that all states
rights people are racism states rights
is an important part of federalism
and it means that we can accomplish some
things in the States so I have this
conversation all the time on the show
but also probably because I'm a big
states rights guy and and what people
will say to me sometimes even just a
conversation I was having this weekend
someone was saying to me well I just
don't trust that the states will do the
right thing that the southern states
will do all these backwards social
things or all that stuff now I've had
many people on here including Randy
Barnett who I'm sure you're familiar to
talk about the foot vote and that you
should leave states and take your
economic value and your personal value
and your family and move somewhere else
in that that's wonderful and
irritability that's the beauty of
America do you think that's a sound
enough argument for states rights well
it that you can just pick up and go it
has it helps a lot it takes a while to
do that I guess I would argue for the
way that we've elaborated states rights
which is we take the first ten
amendments to the Constitution the Bill
of Rights and we apply those also to
state laws through incorporation through
the Fourteenth Amendment so there are
limits on what the states can do but
other than that yes the states can have
all sorts of different things and the
9th and 10th amendments both reserved a
bunch of powers to the states and that I
think the expansion through the commerce
clause and we're sort of getting down in
the weeds but the expansion of federal
powers at the expense of the states has
been one of the catastrophes in
constitutional jurisprudence and I hope
we'll go back in the other direction but
it does
seemed like that president Trump's
appointment seemed to be more like Tenth
Amendment skeptics right well even just
in the last week you know there's some
it's a little confusing what the truth
is but it sounds like sessions may go
after the states because of medical
marijuana these are the things that I
just simply don't understand if the
Republicans or conservatives or the
Trump people whatever whatever that is
wouldn't you want to take a stand that
would that would make some logical
consistency you'd get decent liberals to
go yeah you're doing the right thing
well because that would mean that you
would be operating on principle and not
politics and I guess I had hoped and I'm
now disappointed that our Republican
friends have not done that all they've
done is what they decried in others when
Obama was president okay now we're in
power and we'll do all this stuff that
we rightly criticized Obama for doing
that means that you have no principle at
all what does that tell you about power
in general like that the second they get
this and it's still a little unclear to
me what sessions is doing about the
medical marijuana thing but if you was
to do anything other than respect states
rights it shows me that once you have
power you just suck more power I think
it's it isn't inevitable there used to
be a norm of deference to the
Constitution and to some extent of
forbearance or toleration so you know
I'm Catholic clearly I think that that's
the correct religion all others are
mistaken I also think that you get to
want whatever you get to believe
whatever you want it's that that second
norm of toleration that's being wiped
away and we're going to end up just
being a bunch of competing interest
groups so I don't think it's inevitable
that power is so seductive but there if
if other people it's like standing in
line if a bunch of us come up to
something and there's more of us than
can get through it we just automatically
stand in line but if somebody cuts in
line you say you can't do that but if a
bunch of people cuts in line the line
breaks so our the norm of toleration
that we actually require that this sense
that it's wrong to do this just because
it's wrong even though I have the power
that's breaking down and I don't think
that institution can easily be rebuilt
yeah do you see that breaking down in
sort of every facet of public life right
now like thermo
before we started we were talking about
the media and it seems that mainstream
media norms are crumbling and we have
activists activists that are now
masquerading as journalists this is a
huge problem well for a very long time
in a number of different professions
there were sort of guild rules that is I
have to act as a professional or I will
lose the respect of my colleagues and
that respect comes from doing things the
right way not taking positions that are
correct according to the liberal or
conservative catechism it's doing things
the right way it's actually doing real
reporting instead both sides are
substituting what Stephen Colbert called
truthiness yeah which is there's an
essential truth that exists irrespective
of the facts and the facts are not
evidenced they're examples that makes a
world of difference
you're quarreling with my examples I
have other ones well no if you say
something that's not a fact that means
you're not a professional yeah you
should be embarrassed that's what we're
losing is those norms of professionalism
where do you think that started or when
do you think excited the most famous
incident was dan Rather and some
producers at CBS with the letters from
the Alabama National Guard about George
W Bush and the letters were provided by
someone he said he'd found him in some
files but when you looked at and it was
pretty clear that they couldn't have
been done on an IBM Selectric typewriter
they're proportional font they had the
wrong size footnotes and they should
have backed off they don't made a
mistake mm-hmm they did they doubled
down and said well but there's an
essential truth here and so what
happened was and this is the origin of
the pajamas media the CBS producer said
something he thought was true that
turned out to be true in a way he didn't
expect which was who are you going to
believe
CBS ministers a guy in his basement
wearing pajamas well it turns out that
the guy in the basement wearing pajamas
is pretty good at fact-checking and so
but it didn't start there but that was a
catalyzing moment where people said I
mean CBS News Edward Armour this is as
professional as it gets
and they substituted their own
ideological judgment for any sort of
concern about facts the guy in the
basement seems to be getting more
powerful these days do you view that as
a net grid the power is asymmetric we
cannot discover truth what we can do is
in teach falsehood so the guy in the
basement is pretty good at checking and
seeing if there's something
contradictory to a claim that you've
made and what that means is that no one
can believe anything now because there's
always someone who's checking on it and
saying maybe making this up oh there
there there's a quote in a tweet and
it's - a link and they just assert
something it becomes a fact yeah this is
a problem so it's a profitable program
so it's a terrible problem so then how
do you as a political science professor
it's someone that's trying to frame this
for young minds how do you give them
something that they don't walk out of
your class at the end of the semester
and go oh man we're screwed or maybe
they do and that's how you eventually
fix things well I I want them to walk
out of class saying we could be screwed
we have an obligation to try to act
against this and one of those
obligations is to do the right thing
even when it's not in our self-interest
and so one of my students from a while
back from Duke is a guy named Brendan
Nyhan
at Dartmouth College who writes a lot
about this sort of problem and so I
think if you if readers are interested
if you look at Brendan ion's work on
this question of I think there is some
hope in this direction but it's going to
we're going to have to enlist the aid of
more of the mainstream media and the
problem that you have is you may just
lose the ratings war yeah if you're not
interesting and provocative have we
already crossed that point it seems to
me we that the election got us to sort
of parity between the online media and
the mainstream media like that night it
sort of became equal and now at this
point I think the online media actually
has more influence and that's sort of
why the clickbait style and and the some
of the stuff that we've seen with CNN
over the last couple weeks that's why
it's gotten crazier because they're
they're just grasping
for the last bit of relevancy let's put
a more hopeful spin like this it is true
remember we talked about states rights
were misused by segregationists well
it's true that some of the power for
curation of the mainstream media was
misused and we now we no longer trust
them but it's much easier now to produce
content and I it's self-serving but your
show is a sign that people are actually
willing to spend more than three or four
minutes or 140 characters and try to
understand things so there is this
desire to know if not the truth at least
the nuance of the different claims yeah
and the ability to leapfrog what you can
just put something up on YouTube you get
subscribers and to some extent that's
going to determine something like
ratings so you don't have to go through
these institutions that until now have
meant that only a relative few people
could participate in the conversation
yeah but do you fear the Wild West
factor but I do the best job I can but
people sometimes say to me Dave you're
the only person I trust I go man this is
a huge problem I'm doing the best I can
truly we're in a transition yeah and the
Wild West actually wasn't that bad in a
way there's a book by Carrie Anderson
and PJ Hill called the not so wild wild
west they talk about the California Gold
Fields and the fact that people came up
with ways of allocating property rights
and adjudicated dispute so for a little
while yes it was bad but people realize
what just sucks we can do better than
this right and they organized themselves
or I think within five years we're going
to look back on this time as a time of
transition but not as a time of
catastrophe
new institutions are going to emerge
because the ability to curate and
provide news that people can rely on as
much fun as it is just always to be
outraged listen I think we're going to
come up with new institutions because
the stakes are too high yeah and I hope
we do I mean as someone that's an
outsider for that crumbling thing which
I think it should crumble I do want some
new institutions to exist because
otherwise we're just going to filter
ourselves into into total distance from
each other we're in a way the
catastrophe that is the Trump
administration
it means that a whole lot of people it
happens that editor for The Weekly
Standard Bill Kristol is a friend of
mine his daughter went to Duke I know
not a fan of Trump not really a fan of
Trump attends a conservatism that should
be great he's got a Republican Congress
Republican president but he's saying no
principles more important than power so
for a libertarian and obviously you get
bills not of libertarians but not he's
not a libertarian but but for a
libertarian do you do think Trump has
been a disaster because I can see
arguments that make some sense
libertarian wise in terms of some of the
state stuff and some of taxes stuff but
kind of makes sense on a traditional
libertarian or even conservative side
and then some of the bigger government
things that don't make sense
I think Jeff session is the worst
presidential appointment of my lifetime
Wow he's a disaster and that alone the
sort of those states rights no Fourth
Amendment Jeff Sessions is terrible uh I
have some friends including Walter block
at Loyola University in New Orleans who
is hoping that Trump will be something
good on foreign policy I think you can
make that argument I don't think that I
think Trump's inability even to consider
rule of law and the constitutional
restrictions on the presidency it makes
even worse the slide that we've been in
for an expansion of an imperial
presidency so I worry that all of those
bonds are now going to be broken and
we're going to look for the big man the
Messiah and we're just going to trade
back and forth between different visions
of that and that can never work yeah and
that goes exactly to where we started
this conversation about looking for that
Messiah do you think that our
institutions are actually strong enough
I mean I'm a believer that these
institutions still have enough power
that if compass to do something truly
illegal or truly overstepping executive
authority that even though the
Republicans control Congress that there
that we still have enough juice left in
the system to take care of that so that
I think would sort of mitigate some of
my fears about him for sure absolutely
system is pretty strong in a way so
James Madison in Federalist 51 said that
the structure of the government should
be such that ambition is made to
counteract ambition so you can be a
Republican member of the Senate but you
look in the mirror you see a god man I
am a badass right I have the power of
the Senate here the president is trying
to use executive orders I don't like
that much because it makes me less
powerful as a senator and so a number of
people in the Senate I think will use
Madison's ambition must be made to
counteract ambition incite to limit
Trump at some point yeah so as a guy
that I can tell obviously you're not a
big Trump fan but you still trust in the
system what do you make of when you hear
someone like Maxine Waters constantly
saying we're going to figure out a way
to impeach him you know like we don't
know what it is yet but we're going to
get there that to me that is almost more
undermining of the system than the
excess is that Trump may or may not have
or may or may not be doing at the moment
I agree with everything you said except
almost oh it is more undermining of the
system so we don't have a parliamentary
system where a vote of no-confidence is
enough it takes high crimes and
misdemeanors and I was actually proud of
the American system in 1998 where for no
good reason Bill Clinton there's a lot
of problems with Bill Clinton but he was
impeached in the Senate II this is
stupid
well I think that that would happen
again there's the Democrats were very
upset when there was a movement among
Republicans to say we should impeach
Barack Obama mm-hmm so I think that this
made us be background and the nice way
to interpret it is it's a way for
Democrats to raise money from their base
they don't actually mean it but it just
needs read need a little oh yeah right
which is also pretty horrible okay but
you're saying it yeah means that you're
undermining the rule of law you're
actually doing what you say you're upset
at Trump for doing yeah so is there
anyone in politics right now that you
look at you go these guys basically on
board with
with the principles that I believe in it
won't surprise you to learn that I
admire Rand Paul yeah and I actually
like the Gary Johnson I really do it
let's talk about him for a little bit
let's just talk about him within the
framework of libertarian politics I've
had him on the show I spent time with
him about a half-hour before we were on
air I think he's a totally lovely guy
really and I enjoyed talking to him and
I could see us being friends actually
but the candidacy was pretty terrible it
was the greatest ever it was three times
as much as we've ever gotten before we
got three percent that's amazing that
was enough for ballot access in many
states but do you think that might have
just been a function of discussed with
the other two that sort that Gary
himself that unfortunately just seemed
ill-equipped to be up there and have
enough of a command of the issues well
by the way I say that with total
sympathy for him because there was
nothing he could do to get in the news
except flub they would only talk about
it when he flub so he was in an
unwinnable position he is so much better
than anything else that we have had and
I mean I'm actually a libertarian
partisan I ran for governor of North
Carolina in 2008 I did not win yeah but
we're gonna get to that well I I
campaigned with Gary Johnson I got I got
to know him pretty well yes he flopped
the he was tired he made a bunch of
mistakes and that's what the media
emphasized it was really important that
he got three percent and in fact if you
were to look suppose you strip away the
party labels and your visitor from Mars
yeah well there's this person who has
been a Secretary of State and has
experienced as a senator and then
there's these two people who were multi
term governors of pretty mixed States
and then some psycho person in realistic
you don't think all right those are the
libertarian candidate so I my question
would be compared to what I thought Gary
Johnson did a great job yeah he does he
did the best of libertarian candidate
has ever done they gave us something to
build on did I cringe at the Aleppo
incident of course yeah well that's the
thing I in August I I endorsed him
basically with the idea let's get the
guy to 15% so that at least for one
debate because we know the Democrats and
Republicans control the debate at least
one debate because they'd never let him
in a second one but at least for one
let's hear some of these limited
government ideas and unfortunately there
just wasn't enough juice there but you
know what I'm hearing you and maybe I
will ease off a little quick there's
compared to what yeah you got 3% the
best we ever did was 1% all right so
then what does that mean to you is the
is the future for the Libertarian Party
and do you think that a third party
actually can if that three percent means
something to you do you think that that
means it could be six percent in 2020
could it could it be really impactful in
2020 third parties in a system of
first-past-the-post which is what we
have you're always going to have two
main parties in a first-past-the-post
system but the positions of the parties
will depend partly on the pressure
that's bought brought to bear and if you
have someone you can't participate in
debates particularly at the state level
you can remind the two state sponsored
parties of the things that are in their
platform that they're leaving out so I
don't think a third party is going to
win but what I care about is the
policies not the face of remember I care
about rules and not the people yeah so
if the two state-sponsored parties are
obliged by opening up to the the
scolding wins of competition and they
have better policies that that's what I
hope that the third parties can do yeah
I hear people on the right all the time
say well if we back a libertarian what
you end up doing is splitting the vote
on the right and then you help people on
the Left how would you explain to
somebody that that may not matter and
maybe that has to happen well you only
get one vote and sometimes people do
advocate what political scientists call
voting the lote lesser of two evils if
you vote for the lesser of two evils
you're certainly going to get an evil
right the only way to waste your vote is
to vote for a candidate you don't
actually want and if you vote for a
candidate that you do want that's going
to give a signal to the two
state-sponsored parties that we don't
find this to be acceptable so but all
your votes are wasted they don't
determine the outcome now what I get
then is conservatives particularly
saying what if everyone thought that way
ah you are yours
it affects thousands of others No right
you have one vote you can choose to
waste it or you can vote what you
actually believe and try to send a
signal yeah which I think would be more
important than just throwing it away
well but I start to evil I would think
that there I think we've gotten stuck in
this lesser of two evils as the two
parties have gotten more and more evil
yeah do you think part of that also is
that the whole system now when I say the
system I mean our political system and
our media system there's only a certain
type of person who would run but and now
we can talk a little bit also about your
2008 campaign but but it would take you
know the idea of having to deal with
what your family will have to deal with
they're going to track down every email
that you ever had every if I get an
affair or whatever it is just all that
method you're only going to get a
certain type of person that wants to do
this and that basically good decent
people will self select out I hear this
all the time every time I see somebody
or I talk to somebody that I think
should be in politics that wouldn't want
to subject myself to that but many
guests hear that privately I said you
want to run for something and everyone
no never
there's really two problems one is the
process of running is very difficult
takes a lot of time and you constantly
have your motives questioned and it's
psychologically very difficult the other
problem is if you win you have to serve
and a lot of people that are really good
at things are really good at things
they're doing something else so you have
to be the sort of person who that I
don't want to say too much about Donald
Trump but just thinks that yourself is
being essentially available and the
problem is we as voters validate that so
I found often in debates and talking to
people voters would ask a question about
some policy and I feel that's actually
really complicated that's something
experts disagree about here are the two
arguments you can see their eyes glazing
over and my opponents would say I know
exactly the right thing to do and here
it is and then they would say something
stupid but that wins salient I know what
to do is always going to win over this
is heart yeah
which is also a great argument for small
government to admit it every now and I
don't know what to do so maybe we
shouldn't be you know passing just
things that are going to completely
change the system because the truth is
nobody knows what comes out on the other
side and the fact that something is a
problem doesn't mean that there's a
solution so the I I call that the we
should do something problem X is a
problem ok we should do something Y is
something
therefore we should do Y it doesn't
follow the fact that something should be
done but then they'll say well you don't
care about X so unemployment and poverty
are problems and so there are these
things that we should do right and I
said well those things won't work oh you
hate pork yeah and it's almost
impossible to to extricate yourself out
of that right sorry so you ran as
libertarian candidate for governor of
North Carolina in 2008 so first off
within since you I can tell you're a
real politic person why not just run as
a Republican which would have perhaps
given you a better shot just just start
just we're giving the reality of I live
in North Carolina yeah our Democrats are
Republicans our Republicans are Taliban
they're there they want Sharia law now
it's Christian Sharia law right right so
they're vet so this is the real
Christian right I would have come in
eighth in a seven-person primary if I
had run as a Republican uh-huh so there
there really is no constituency in North
Carolina among the Republicans for my
view of conservatism but if the
Democrats or Republicans why not run as
a Democrat end the I considered running
as a Democrat but the Democrats have had
a machine that controlled the state and
it was clear who the nominee was going
to be I also might the reason that I ran
was my objection to North Carolina's
ballot access laws we have some of the
most restrictive ballot access laws in
the country if Coke and Pepsi could
decide on many soft drinks there should
be they would say to the Republicans and
Democrats actually get to do that and
they think 2 is the right number yeah so
all I did we had to raise about three
hundred thousand dollars to get on the
ballot and then we could
ever get enough votes to stay on the
ballot so eight times we've spent all
this money all this collection of
signatures yeah I figured that I could
get 2% it takes 2% to stay on the ballot
we've never done that so if you set your
goals really low you could be a success
I got more than 2% so I figured I could
do that and I did that was my objective
yeah I get the 2% I got 2.8 percent do
you think that some of those ideas that
you were running on in 2008 have taken
root in North Carolina they were at
least mentioned by the other candidates
and sometimes the newspapers would even
point this out also I was in for
televised debates and in some ways I'm
their worst nightmare I have a PhD in
economics I'm a certain superficial
glibness and I'm not about winning so I
could answer the questions yeah I
haven't got the superficial glitch maybe
it'll come or maybe you're very
effective at it and I've minutes thank
you what do you think is the reason that
the libertarians haven't done more at
the state level when people talk about
the libertarians they go well Gary
Johnson or whatever is right and and yes
there is Rand Paul but technically he's
a Republican salutely there's Justin
Amash there's a couple people but why
haven't they done more just on the local
level it seems like a major opening for
them coming over here I was promising
myself I wasn't going to answer this
question but what the heck go crazy I'll
say here's what happens at libertarian
meetings the first one twenty or thirty
people show up and they're all
enthusiastic yeah and at the second
meeting 10 people show up and the 10 say
I'm really glad those others didn't come
back they want real libertarians because
what they're mainly concerned about is
checking each other's papers so you can
tell if it's a real libertarian meeting
by how long is it before there's an
argument about whether individuals
should be able to own nuclear weapon
yeah nobody cares about that when I was
running for governor
people would say would you end the Fed
yeah I'm running for governor exactly
this is not a stay yeah but I want to
know so what we really care about is
ideological purity because if you cared
about actual policy or winning you would
suck it up and be a Democrat a
Republican right so the problem that we
have as libertarians is that I don't
think people conceive themselves as
being part of a political process they
think of themselves as Oh Trey as being
outside and truth-tellers the keepers of
a last flickering remnant of truth yeah
and that's just not a very effective
political strategy that's interesting
because to me after doing this show for
about two years and having you know a
lot of classical liberals on a lot of
libertarians and I've had progressives
and conservatives and everything that to
me basically the difference that I see
between classical liberals and
libertarians is a little more realistic
utility for the state so when someone
comes into with that question and says
to you what are you going to get rid of
the Fed you got money for governor and
also that's a really high-level
philosophical thing that we you know
that to me it's just it's just a more
realistic approach to how to change
things do you think that's a fair
assessment yes and I've made a
distinction in a couple of things that
I've written between directional and
destination lists libertarians
destinations libertarians have a
particularly Bert Opia in mind in
anything that's not like that
is out the directional lists would want
to say are there policies that we could
choose that would be cheaper lower
deficits lower the power of the state
and increase personal responsibility and
liberty so an example would be when I
was running for governor what my
educational platform was vouchers and a
lot of people means-tested vouchers so
the poorest 40% would get more school
choice many of the wealthy have it now
let's have more school choice for the
very poor and a lot of people on the
Left we're kind of interested in that
there's a lot of african-american
citizens that are just desperate to get
their school their children into better
schools and libertarians almost without
exception said oh no the state would be
involved in that
the only acceptable libertarian policy
is the immediate elimination of all
taxes right again this is the part that
is not the realistic part because their
destination is
so the destination estar always going to
be there the libertarians are they're
going to have any success are going to
have to appeal to the directional list
in both parties but say look the
government has too many powers we may
disagree about how far back we want to
move it but let's move the Train in the
other direction we're going the wrong
way I think there's a consensus we
should move it back where we get off the
train that's a
different questions yeah but let's
change the direction what would you say
is the easiest way to explain state
power when I mean state I mean local or
federal to the person that doesn't quite
get this to the person that when you
talk about government power and
governmental reason they don't kind they
just think it's like you're talking
about some sort of ephemeral thing that
doesn't really do we think the best
argument to get them to start
understanding the ideas of why of what
Liberty really is well this is obviously
something I've thought about a lot and I
haven't really succeeded so you're
asking what the best argument it is but
it's very frustrating because people
have a conception of a thing called a
state so something I've written a lot
about is the unicorn conception of the
state so imagine that I have a mass
transit proposal and what we'll have is
these large carts that are called by
unicorns and unicorns are great for mass
transit because they eat rainbows that
are very strong and they're flatulent
smells like fresh strawberries so
there's no emission he's not know that
fight it's what there's no emissions
problem that got really great now you
could object well I think there's a
problem with this actually because
unicorns don't really exist
close your eyes yeah you see one yeah
so why they totally exist in the sense
that I can imagine them that's how
people think of the state when I say
here's look the state is messing up well
right because we are bad people
all we need to do is get the right debt
battery because I can imagine a state
that's doing these things it's very
difficult to fight that so the argument
that I try to make haven't given that
caveat yeah that it's hard to fight
unicorns because that's what people want
is something they can imagine not
something that exists but the argument
that I actually try to make is that
every flaw in consumers and there are
many is worse in voters
so you think consumers are too stupid to
be able to choose what size Coke to buy
mm-hmm or which car to buy voters have
all those problems and more so my
colleague Dan Ariely at Duke who writes
about rationality and consumer problems
and once the state to intervene there's
no such thing as the state there's just
people
if we're going to have voters choose
what these experts are going to make
people do it'll be even worse than the
market right so it's I so basically we
are the flaw in the system that in a
really perverse way that the best system
is one that recognizes that and doesn't
try to do too much because if we give
voters enough power they'll do what they
did in the south and afflicts minorities
they'll though or they'll say no
same-sex marriage there's no reason to
think that if you take one person who's
too stupid to make his own choices at
the grocery store and put them together
in that we can anger Iman effects right
they can then choose a good president or
a good food and drug administration so
let's talk about that mob for a second
because I sense that both sides right
now are being led by their mob I see it
more on the left but I do see it on the
right as well that just the hysterical
people who have all the magical answers
who have if it was only their Messiah so
the hysterical people on the right they
have their Messiah in office right now
but they're hysterical people on the
left that if they only had Bernie it
would all be okay the middle it's hard
to get that middle mob to get going
right it was very difficult to be deeply
committed to moderation so um Yates has
that poem where he says the worst are
full of passionate intensity while the
best lack all conviction because you
think well this is actually hard there's
a bunch of people think it's not her
they know exactly what to do and
politics if it's going to work
needs to have rules institutions
constitutions that prevent them from
being able to control the government and
that's the the genius of what our
Constitution has done that separation of
powers I understand it's really
frustrating because it means that there
you feel strongly there seems to be
majority in favor of it and yet we still
can't do it because the president
doesn't go along the Supreme Court
doesn't go along it means that a lot of
times the status quo is privileged but
the alternative is to have a mob and
Plato when he thought of democracy
actually talked about too much Liberty
means that you've got
the butler's that are drunk on on
Liberty's head ey right and that they'll
say if they find a leader who doesn't
give them too much they'll call them
black words and oligarchs but you should
do exactly what we want well they don't
actually know what what they want so we
have a real problem in and this is an
interesting paradox in democracy there
was a famous Englishman that said the
reason that we put our leaders heads on
stamps is that we can thumb their noses
and lick their Hydra parks so we have
both of those attitudes towards leaders
we want them to be better than us and to
do what we say yeah is part of this also
that we think that we need to get our
morals from our leaders too and maybe
that's changing a little bit with Trump
but that we thought that you know they
always want you're going to be married
you can have the perfect family we're
going to show you the kids we know that
it's always a fraud and they're all
cheating on their wives and doing all
sorts of awful things but that we've
tried to make our politicians and to be
perfect humans which again is been
Massiah thing you're talking about but
it's just it's just show sure it's
difficult we have other things you know
there's basketball to watch they're not
there's baseball there's picnics to go
on we don't really want to have to watch
politicians very closely and so we
substitute I was really surprised at
this how little voters knew or cared
about actual issues the issue that I is
a political scientist I want to talk
about that right other than one I got a
go I really am not interested in that at
all oh but it's an important issue yeah
I'm out I'm sorry yeah what they're
interested instead is your character so
if your character is very much like them
it means that you'll go off and when
they're not watching they'll do what
they would have done you will do what
they would have done right and so they
want you to know are you like me in
terms of core values yeah and that's why
family and things like that matter is
that you're a good person now it the
problem is what Trump is a strange
misnomer in that isn't he he said the
things that many white people believed
Trump won a majority of white women I
think that's the single most astonishing
fact about this election Trump won a
majority of white
and the reason is that the Democrats for
reasons that I have a hard time
understanding mostly campaigned on a
platform of white people suck you guys
are privileged you and there's all sorts
of reasons why actually you can say that
that's true but as a political strategy
it didn't work
and so Clinton when she said why am I
not ahead by 50 points yeah it's amazing
that they didn't recognize that they had
actually to appeal to a majority of
Americans not to try to put together a
coalition of disparate interest groups
that are united by nothing except the
promise that they're going to get paid
off so that goes directly to social
justice which I talk about all the time
I assume you see this as a pretty big
threat to the way our political system
should work right it sounds good social
justice but in reality it's it's
creating these competing interests that
have to sort of knock each other down a
peg we're all in favor of justice and
social justice means that we have a
system that works I see social justice
as the claim that there shouldn't be any
unearned privilege and to the extent
that people think they've been denied
something that's where this social
justice warrior impulse comes from it's
particularly interesting being on
college campuses to see what social
justice warriors have done where they
would even allow other people to speak
so there's a there's a broad problem of
free speech and social justice and then
the problem on college campuses that I
have to deal with often personally yeah
the social justice warriors and academic
freedom which is a little bit different
from free freedom of speech academic
freedom is a different concept but the
social justice impulse to the extent
that it's a number of people have said
but I think Milton Friedman said it if
you take money from a and give it to B
it's likely B will vote for you that
doesn't mean that it's the right thing
to do just campaigning with other
people's money yeah and so all of us are
clever we can come up with reasons why
you should get some
and you should get something and you
should get something but at some point
you run out of other people's money yeah
and you've just split now this thing
into a gajillion editing so discussing
this on the campus front how bad is it
on campuses right now I talked to
professors all you know in all sorts of
different disciplines and almost
everybody says it's pretty terrible I'm
really spoiled because I'm a Duke
so I mean you probably heard about how
bad Charles Murray's visit to Duke was
probably didn't because it was fine
we had Charles Murray in oh wait which
was the one you got me that Richard the
one that was the hole yeah the water
there was a number of places that
charles murray try out okay i have
turned out really badly he came to Duke
there were three idiots with blue Busey
the room was quite you couldn't even
hear it yeah it was fine people asked
some questions in fact I asked that they
asked more rude questions he's a
grown-up yeah happy to answer agressive
rude questions so I think that the
answer is I have an odd view probably
I'm a big fan of safe spaces yeah so you
wrote I wanted to ask you about it so
you wrote a piece on unlearn liberty in
defense of safe spaces which as I read
it you parse it to a point that actually
makes some sense to me because I'm not a
safe space guy so take it away well it's
an attempt at judo obviously I'm using
safe space in a way where people who
were in favor of safe spaces they go
yeah yeah wait what right so you kind of
flip it so can you
well it to me the the main principle
universities are operating on is not
freedom of speech we can say anything
you want but academic freedom which
means that you can go up into little
groups and be insulated from people that
you disagree with so you can work on
something so the political scientists
are working on something in a particular
way in sociology is working on something
in a particular way we have communities
of scholars that work on things and in
our talks there's a bunch of things that
are shared premises shared assumptions
and we're going to try to advance
without constantly having to confront
all of the other possible ways of
thinking about
right so so you're describing that as a
safe space but I feel like that's not
exactly what the like I don't know that
many people would argue that that isn't
okay right even the people that are
first sakes well but the then we can go
on to raise the question and Van Jones
has this amazing video where he makes
exactly the right argument I think what
you cannot do is annex the entire
university as a safe space you cannot
say I want to be all across the
university safe from anything that I
disagree with so that it's the very fact
that there's these different safe spaces
that nearly ensure there's going to be
somebody working on things you totally
disagree with and they have to be safe
within that space you don't get to
prevent them from doing that so I think
we need safe spaces for examples for
fraternities and that's the feel the
safe space people are Ned the sweeper
County later painted area they know
people need to be able to come up with
associations so there's five freedoms
that are guaranteed in the First
Amendment and we forget freedom of
association freedom Association means I
get to choose the people that I hang out
with and if I want to have a club or
organization and we have rules and we
want to talk about the stuff we want to
talk about in having the speakers that
we want even if it's milah mm-hmm okay
but people seem to be lost on us I mean
I don't infused I see even with the
guests that we choose here if I choose
one person someone will love me for a
year then I put on one person who they
don't like
suddenly they prescribe all of that
person's beliefs on to me I go well I
was just asking them question and and
listening to the answers and you can
either turn it off or maybe you'll learn
something
yeah John Stuart Mill has this great
idea of Education where he says it
requires collision with air and the way
I try to explain it to people is I think
this happens much more on the left but a
lot of the young students on the Left
have just learned one move chess
openings they move the pawn in front of
their king out to spaces and then
they're patted on the head it's good
yeah and somebody knows a five move
chess opening in response they're really
upset can you do that
well you must be a bad person in fact
we're going to prevent that because I
don't know why your argument is false
the only possible explanation is that
it's evil yeah is that your racist
bigoted homophobic setter because
they've never actually had to confront
people that they disagreed with yeah so
collision with error means that you're
constantly trying to improve your own
views because if you find someone you
disagree with one of two things is true
either you're right but you don't know
the reasons and you should think about
it because not knowing the reasons is a
lot like not knowing the truth
memorizing some catechism of truths is
not what college is about it's learning
reasons and being able to reason
critically now you can't do that unless
you know the best argument against your
position so one of the things I'm pretty
judgmental about this
I'll ask people that's an interesting
claim what do you think is the best
counter-argument to that and if they say
well there isn't one we're done you
don't know anything but if they say you
know there's actually two that I have a
real problem with and I think I can
answer them but they're interesting
arguments that person's an intellectual
yeah it's funny because some of my best
moments you can see the way I interview
and I'm really I haven't looked down at
the notes once and I'm trying to hear
you and just go where it feels natural
but some of my best moments on the show
I think or where someone has pinned me
into thinking wait a min I really have
to re-evaluate something and that's how
that's how you evolve and that's how
most of us are and yet we've so let go
of that in the in the public and where
some of its generational a lot of the
young students just have never thought
about the problem of having to learn by
arguing so one of the things that I do
in class and it's it worked better than
I thought was I divide the students into
pairs and they have to choose a question
they're going to debate and then on the
day of the debate in the debates or
thirty minutes on the day of the debate
both of them hold up big ass yellow dice
there's not enough ritual in our lives
right so you have to hold the dice over
your head and you roll it whoever gets
the higher roll gets to choose which
side ah and I go which side you're
arguing until that moment yeah how does
a co it they love it because they
actually they pay much more attention
now to things they disagree with because
they want to understand it they may have
to argue it do you find that sometimes
the ones that are arguing things they
don't believe actually do a better job
because of that because they're actually
try they're do they have to do more
intellectual work and they're not so
emotional where I have an attachment to
a particular position it's hard for me
to explain it because I just know it's
right yeah
whereas if it's an argument I don't
agree with I'm thinking of it logically
step-by-step and I'm presenting evidence
so in a lot of times they end up saying
well I kind of got to change my mind
that's not really what I believed after
all or at least I can see why someone
would believe the opposite that's what
education is yeah so it sounds like your
situation at Duke is pretty good and
maybe they've they've managed to figure
out the free speech thing a little bit
better than most universities Duke is
really committed to it and the thing is
it's not very hard thing to commit to so
our previous president nan cohan's the
best college president I've ever seen
and there was an incident where David
Horowitz had bought this ad about how
reparations for slavery were racist and
you know it was pretty incendiary and I
didn't like the ad I thought it was out
of line but the newspaper the Duke
Chronicle had allowed the David Horowitz
to purchase a one-page ad now he had
done that in a number of newspapers he
did it at Brown University at Brown
University they had a ceremonial burning
of the newspapers on the steps of the
admin building in which the president
participated
that's horrible yeah Duke what nan cohan
said was it's a newspaper you want to
buy an ad go ahead right that's not a
very hard position to take it's a
newspaper I might not have taken that at
his editor I'm not editor you want to
contest it by an ad so do you think that
the students or the faculty or whatever
was at Brown when they do that sort of
thing do you think they realize that
they ultimately strengthen the ideas
that they're going up against so for
example I've had David Horowitz on the
show I think he's a decent guy I agree
with him on some stuff you know you he
was a former leftist and
I think 30 years ago was struggling with
a lot of the issues that I'm thinking
about these days
but basically I sat across from I
thought he's a decent guy I didn't think
he was some right-wing maniac or all the
things that they say about him so that
when they then you know burn the
newspapers or whatever and then now you
have people doing a little research on
him and then they may go well this isn't
all crazy what he's saying go look at
the reaction to him then oh the one
alternative would be looking the news
experiments oh geez and today all right
that would be the same as we wasted all
that money because they're not persuaded
by it because I'll play yeah as if
people are paying that much attention to
newspaper ads you know well they did
after the people administering at Brown
burned it that got so much attention
yeah so if nothing else it certainly
does validate two claims one the
university is not capable of holding
legitimate discussions or confrontations
with ideas you disagree with and the
other is I'm going to look at this ad
and see what it says because it's pretty
controversial yeah so we've got about 50
minutes and we really haven't done that
much on economics oh I do I want to
shift a little bit because to me it
seems that economics if we could get the
economic system to work right whatever
that means but it does resolve a lot of
the political things basically if people
have jobs and can you know buy some
stuff and feel the talen property and
things of that nature that those other
things will become less important that's
my basic beliefs do you think that's a
fair premise to start off with it's
interesting that so many things are
going on at once because the most recent
recent magazine John Nye at George Mason
University has this brilliant article
about inequality so it is true that if
you look at income levels there's more
inequality and the reason is there's
more rich people and the rich have
gained by more than the poor but the
poor gained a lot so but let's compare
this to 1800 in 1800 the mode of
transportation of the wealthy was very
different from the poor now if I'm
really rich maybe I have a Tesla and you
have a Dodge minivan Chevy Equinox least
it's not that different really it has
air conditioning it works pretty well it
gets
Tesla gets good guess my but there's
some sort of status difference but but
we're basically doing the same we're the
same
yeah we've got an internet connection at
home we've got a nice television uh
we've got a computer we've got a laptop
we've got a cell phone there are some
differences in status but there's never
been more equality in the basic way that
people live their lives and the
difference in if you look at the
difference in life expectancy between
the wealthy and the poor it used to be
enormous and child mortality rates it
was enormous
it's converged our biggest problem is
not starvation it's obesity so there has
never been a time of greater equality
now I know some people are going to hear
that and go I you liberate Aryans what
he's saying is you people on the bottom
have a TV have a cell phone have a what
about the people that don't have that
stuff now I get what you're saying those
that most of the the bottom has sort of
moved up to have a decent level but what
about that other what's the libertarian
view of how you help or not help the
people that don't have that baseline two
things one when historians look back at
the period between 1945 and 2010 the
great story is the worldwide elimination
of policy of poverty through capitalism
every country that has chosen markets
has dramatically improved not just the
average but the least well-off
china-india poverty is disappearing
around the world if by poverty use some
objective measure if you have a
subjective or comparative measure yes
it's a problem because there's always
going to be one fifth of the people in
the bottom 20% that's just a definition
I'm not a mathematician but I think
though is he on that yes so that's one
thing is allowing markets solves poverty
in a way that no government program ever
could it's better to have a job than a
handout on the other hand I have written
quite a bit about my own support for
universal basic income so I think
universal basic income is a better
solution than the hodgepodge of
different introduced
programs that we have now then let me
explain brief yeah why so what we have
is a system and I wrote a pretty
incendiary paper about this the state is
just it is a bad polygamist so if you're
a single mother and you have three
children if you do one of two things
you'll lose your support from the
polygamist if you get a job or get
married if you actually do something
that achieves some independence for
yourself your husband the state will
call we're getting a divorce
right I don't care I'm you can have more
children you can have affairs but you
have to be committed to me you can only
get support from me which means that you
can't do any of the things that normally
we would expect and this is a
conservative position I suppose family
and jobs are good things being married
and having a job is a good thing we have
what many people even on the Left have
called the cliff effect of benefits if
I'm in section 8 housing and I get
subsidies for food I get subsidies for
school the first 10,000 that I earned
costs me $12,000 in benefits so the poor
aren't lazy they're rational right so
they're they're really it's just a
realistic gaint neck I don't know about
ours a game they're not playing a game
but it's a they're making calculations
and Adam in that technical sense yeah
they have choices they have strategies
those have payoffs yeah it's
unsurprising they pick the ones that
make them better off because they're
desperate they can't afford to lose this
money so for example if you're living in
through subsidized housing in a decent
area with a decent school and even if
you don't want those handouts well then
you realize well I'm gonna have to work
in a third job now and then they're
going to force me to move I do a much
worse place to live I can't afford
childcare so the state is a bad
polygamist let's stop doing that and
let's say and another problem as I see
it is minimum wage now the effects of
minimum wage on overall employment
economists debate but it's almost
certainly true that it's very difficult
for people to get a first job or acquire
the experience that allows them to start
the staircase to the American dream so
the unemployment rate
in some urban areas for like fifteen to
twenty five-year-olds is forty fifty
percent there's no way for people to
find a first job why do we do that well
you want to say people should be able to
live on this it's not clear why your
first job should be something you should
be able to live on yeah and if you even
bring that up people get upset well
except I say you know you're right let's
make sure they can live let's give them
universal basic income and if they want
to get a job at three dollars an hour
because that's how you get experience in
Europe in Germany if you serve an
apprenticeship you're making two or
three dollars an hour after two years
you have enough experience you can now
get a job that makes thirty dollars an
hour so it's an education so to me
universal basic income that's given
without strings we take the money that
we're spending now which is enough to
give at least $12,000 per poor people's
you take the amount that we spend divide
it by the number where we taken that
from well all of these different subsidy
per to all of the subsidy programs then
go to so we do include in Social
Security so we eliminate all those yeah
use that money to give everyone a
universal basic income and if they get a
job they don't lose it they get married
they don't lose it they can use it for
childcare one of the problems that
people have now is it's very
specifically tied to a location mm-hmm
so I can't go somewhere where there's a
job because I won't be able to establish
myself universal basic income if it's
federal means that if I'm living in
Cleveland Ohio I can't find a job and
our jobs in Texas or North Carolina when
I get there I get universal basic income
I can establish myself I can pay for
childcare I can look for a job and they
actually are jobs in those places yeah
do you find a conflict between your
libertarian self and your kind of itself
on this because it seems like the idea
of a libertarian going the state should
give people money probably seems like
there's some fight there either if
you're a destination Asst if I'm a
directionless I say dude we're giving
them the money now right we're already
doing it we're already doing it let's
just give the money in a way that's
cheaper and increases liberty that's the
basic directionless Targ ument which is
why milton friedman and charles murray
are both in favor of the universal basic
income but it has to be a directionless
re we're already
doing that now you're saying we
shouldn't do that great good for you we
are and unless you have some plan to end
that and improve things I'll listen to
that right that's not what they say they
just say well the government shouldn't
be giving out any money it already is
let's do it in a more efficient way and
in a way that increases Liberty because
I can then spend that money on what I
actually want we give these vouchers for
food which I don't really want to buy
that I want to buy something else I sell
my food stamps for 50 cents on the
dollar mm-hmm
if I get money I already have a hundred
cents on the dollar now the one
objection that people on the Left people
on the Left make is well those poor
people you know how they are they'll
spend it on the wrong stuff so what I
want to do is a key argument of people
on the Left make I think that isn't it
usually from the right where they'll say
they're going to spend it on them or
some people but at a surprising number
of people left believe that yeah so one
of the things I like about this is it
sort of divides the usual political
split by a paternalistic they are
there's a whole bunch of people on the
Left that really think experts and
honestly which white people should be
saying here's how these poor people
should be spending their time and money
yeah which is probably not well that
shows you about a lot about paternalism
and authoritarianism and all that so
your next book which is called tomorrow
3.0 this is sort of partly what it's
going to be about right because that
we're going to about to go into another
revolution which is going to be a shared
economy and technological revolution and
that all sort of plays into I suppose
basic income and just the way technology
is you know iPads ever play some people
at McDonald's this is just a fact it's
interesting so Marc Andreessen in
November 2011 wrote a piece for The Wall
Street Journal in which he said software
eats the world and what he meant was
that software is to service jobs as
robots and automation are to productions
and we're used to thinking of factories
as being a transformation from a bunch
of people putting stuff together to
machine's putting stuff together and
it's more efficient but it means there's
fewer jobs
so capitalism almost always reduces jobs
by increasing productivity as the Trump
was wrong and saying that we're sending
jobs to China the whole world is losing
jobs for productivity and that's good
because consumer products are reduced in
price and it means that we're all
wealthier the reason that everyone
almost everyone can afford a car and a
cellphone is that the price of those
things has fallen so much problem is
until now we've said well there's always
the service economy people can always
get service jobs they can't and that's
being hastened by the push for increased
minimum wages so in Seattle for example
if you have a fast-food restaurant
you're probably investigating kiosks so
you don't have to pay $15 an hour to
have some guy really isn't worth $15 an
hour at the front desk right so the
service jobs are going to be taken over
by software it's not clear to me that
we're going to be able to take people
who are not sufficiently well trained by
the state education system to be able to
work in the new economy to make that
transition very quickly so I think
universal basic income you can make a
static argument we're spending the money
already
mm-hmm so when might as well spend it
more efficiently but then there's a
dynamic argument to overtime the move to
the sharing economy probably benefits
most of us yeah because we can rent
rather than own prices are going to fall
dramatically we'll need a lot less stuff
the sharing economy just just so people
for the people that don't really get it
so basically that you wouldn't even have
to necessarily own your car that all of
the all of the things that we kind of
have would we figure out better ways to
use them so you wouldn't have to fork
out as much money for them in the first
place and we'd figure out well I'm going
to use it on Tuesdays at this time and
you're going to use it then and that is
that the basic short example that I
always use I think people recognize it
is I have a black BMW 330i and I'm just
the sort of person you think I am that
drives a black BMW 330i zooming in and
out yeah it's a very expensive car I
park it at a special shrine at my house
I approaches the door opens now it's a
garage
that's pretty expensive storage and
since I worked as an administrator at
Duke for a long time I have the parking
space of God yeah I can park in a great
space so my car is really expensive and
it's always taking up two pieces of real
estate the garage and my parking space
at Duke which is reserved for me when
you multiply that by I Drive my car 3040
minutes a week mm-hmm all the rest of
time is just sitting there I think
what's going to happen 50 years from now
is that people are going to look back
and be astonished at the extent to which
we were so selfish that we wanted to
keep stuff so other people couldn't use
it and spend a lot of money storing it
so other people couldn't use it now
there's some extent that gives us status
I'm an old guy I probably have pictures
of my pathetic car on base okay young
people don't do that they're more
interested in accumulating experiences
than they are stuff so I think that
there's a cultural shift towards a
sympathy towards not having such a big
impact on the environment reducing your
footprint mm-hmm so if a car is
constantly in use instead of sitting in
my garage or a parking space all the
time we'll be far fewer of them we'll be
able to have bike lanes because we won't
need to have all this parking space we
won't need to have closets or storage
units where we have all this crap that
we don't even need sorted units are
pretty amazing you have all this stuff
that you're not using and you never go
there well but it but somebody else
could be using it the reason that
they're not using it is that it's too
difficult for you to find that other
person yeah software is going to change
our ability to find someone to share it
with do you find a little bit that that
can be at odds with individualism that
you're not saying that you wouldn't have
the right to own things right it is
that's not the end conclusions of most
people I think want the use of something
and in our current system owning it is
the cheapest way to have something
available to use but it's fairly common
for I don't I have a tuxedo I don't wear
it very often many women have gowns that
they wear maybe once now the reason that
they don't lint the gown is that it's
too difficult to find it in exactly
their size but
suppose you had an app that could take
computer laser measurements and get
exactly the right measurement and it's
delivered to you two days from now and
instead of an $800 gown that you wear
once it's $100 rental and it's a
designer gown that would be great
yeah so everything's changing I think is
the theme of this hour there's a lot
changing politically there's a lot
changing economically and we just got to
be smart enough to hopefully not you
know go totally off the ditch as we're
navigating it I'm I'm mostly optimistic
because I think our institutions are
pretty strong and people recognize that
there's a problem the social media the
internet access to software all create
disruptions but when you look at human
history a lot of the best things have
happened after a period of disruption
but the period disruption can be pretty
bad the 1840s and 50s in Europe cities
were on fire because of the Industrial
Revolution the result was mostly good so
though it's not clear to me what's going
to happen which again is one of the
reasons I'm per universal basic income
let's make sure that those who are least
well-off and who are through no fault of
their own find themselves not able to
work in the traditional manufacturing
jobs that they expected to be there hmm
let's make sure that there's some
minimum on how bad off they are yeah it
said I love the framing of that because
it really is an argument that transcends
the left-right thing because you're
you're hitting them both at their soft
spot so it's got a nice a nice ability
to get some people to come together
we'll see that's an issue for more on
dr. Munger follow him on Twitter
maybe you'll respond right yo you you do
respond four times then you wrote a nice
piece on learn liberty about how when
every now and again you have an
experience that actually changing again
I'm positive there you go follow dr.
Munger on Twitter it's at Monthly
[Music]
you